you
I'm mad camp and I approve this message
my opponents may be speaking in
double-talk but I don't watch their
shows I'm here to tell you what you
really need to believe it
[Music]
stream your defenses holding on to one
defense may work for the 1% but for the
majority of us the everyman view should
be playing the matchups don't trade for
quarterbacks it never leads to a good
return and is often short-sighted we
don't need another arms warm
always follow the dolphin sure it's
trendy to say now but my record shows
I've been following the Dolphins with
great success all season
[Music]
it's time for your fantasy fire
[Music]
Wow from the sports book at Caesar's
Palace in Fabulous Las Vegas is your
fantasy fire drill and here's your host
[Applause]
well no welcome to your fantasy fire
drill America and the fantasy world that
I sell you on myself I'm sorry I look
like that it look a little more normal
now and I'm here with you and weird with
you every single Sunday 11:30 Eastern
8:30 Pacific on your fantasy fire drill
on all bleacher report platforms hey
took seven weeks I finally said it right
I'll be getting your questions in
YouTube I'm looking out for you
specifically later on in the show we're
gonna talk inactives
injuries sleepers plenty of your
questions on the board from some
celebrities in the sports book here in
Las Vegas come out and join us if you're
here but if you're joining us right now
welcome in it is week number seven and
we have to talk some campfire talk we
have to talk about the running back
position now you might be on the right
side of this the wrong side of this at
some point over the next seven weeks as
we move into the fantasy playoffs hint
for later on we're half way home
you're gonna be on the right side of
wrong side of this you're gonna be
dealing with injuries that you didn't
see coming Dalvin cook stay and healthy
love it hope he gets all the way to the
end of the season but if he got hurt
what would you do if you're six and one
right now you're probably not thinking
much about that waiver wire if you are
looking at say quan barkley today you're
happy to have him back but what about
out in the camara
what about the Chargers are doing who
should you play is it Gordon is it
heckler the Chiefs Damian Williams
Darryl Williams
LeSean McCoy it seems to change every
single week the Giants getting say Quan
Barkley back this week but you had to
weather that storm for a couple weeks
even Wayne Gulman got hurt today we're
gonna see Todd Gurley we won't see
Malcolm Brown very likely but we will
asleep Daryl Henderson and the Saints we
already know Alvin Camaros out those are
all big names
thank goodness Christian McCaffrey sir
oh but not hurt but he's on a bye this
week I'm time everything else you have
to deal with this is going to drive us
nuts it's not going to change so what
I'll tell you is this stay digital on
the waiver wire the running back
position is the most volatile and
fantasy football it will be until the
end of time
speaking of volatility and injuries
let's get to our inactives our ins and
for this week your deal will fire weeks
to deal with injuries we'll get to
sleepers but here's what we're at right
now when it comes to the injury some of
these we know already
Tyrell Williams for the Raiders is out
today it's Darryl Waller it's Josh
Jacobs I don't care about any other
Raiders taking on the Packers who will
not have Davante Adams the toe injury
remains there for now
geronimo Allison is in today there's
something good marques Valdez scantling
is also in today so maybe if you were
gonna go oh if one of them was out Adams
out I can plain with confidence to me
their wide receiver threes there flexes
the matchup is not bad at all I will say
that but it's hard to go totally in on
these guys I don't mind Jimmy Graham by
the way is a low-end tight end one for
the weak debo Samuel is out for the
Niners now we've been trying to figure
out who's the guy who's the wide
receiver to go get you know maybe you
take a look at Pettis because Samuels
out today but it's really George Kittel
just having Coleman it's Matt Brina
those are the confident places as much
we love Kyle Shanahan it's about the
confidence to have in those guys wide
receiver there just hasn't been that
stick out guy Chris Thompson's out for
the Redskins today honestly I think it
makes it easier just to avoid them
outside of Terry Maclaurin who remains a
very solid wide receiver to David
Johnson's got the ankles got the back
but he will play today he is a top 10
option Christian Kirk is out today and
honestly if you have them it's better
that he sits down you'll wait for next
week the rehab and all that lot more for
laughing shell coming against the Giants
could be a very big day for life at
shelled and David Johnson and Navy even
chase Evans for that matter sterling
Shepherd but fortunately with the
concussion second one of the season he
is out but names you won't see for the
Giants on this list because they're not
on the injury report say Kwan Barkley
and Evan Engram are back today for the
New York Giants who play them with
confidence Malcolm Brown is doubtful not
expected to play just not officially out
yet but you're not banking on him being
out there now that's three early games
we'll update that later on let's get
into our late game Sunday night Monday
Night Football
Delanie Walker up in the air low end
starter at best anyway I would look for
another option Marquis Brown we're gonna
see this could come down to the wire
later on today hopefully
he's good to go but I would say put him
in your Flex spot so you have more
flexibility of course to pivot to
somebody else
we know alvin kamara we know Jared Cook
are both out today and thank you to the
Saints for telling us that ahead of time
even though you're playing later on
today latavius Murray to me is a decent
flex maybe a low-end RB to match up
against the Bears isn't terrible but
he's no alvin kamara but with both of
these players out a lot of targets could
be coming Michael Thomas's way okay to
pay up for him a DFS Mauri Cooper is
expected to play tonight against the
Eagles honestly I thought he would sit I
don't think he's a hundred percent
I still like Michael Gallup that Eagles
secondary is terrible I could pick
eleven people out sit and watching right
now and I would say they're better than
the Eagles defense so yeah continue to
play Michael Gallup Michener Biscay is
back is that a good thing we're gonna
see he wasn't very good before the
injury hopefully he's better this time
around
Phillip Dorsett and Julian Edelman are
both listed this questionable because
Bill Belichick wants to be a complete
pain in our asses but they're expected
to play Josh Gordon Oh we'll be out on
Monday Night Football and I will say
this a lot of questions about Gordon I
don't think we need to keep him around
cover up his name look at his numbers
tell me if you think that guy has been
any good the season I'll tell you the
answer the answer is no now if he's
depth ok fine but I feel like his name
value keeps him around in your lineup
far too long we'll update those early
game inactives as soon as we have more
information later on in the show but now
we get to your questions because that's
why you're here is week 7 and I got you
covered let's get to these questions
right now
Michael Gallup or Adam Thielen Rockman
you got to go at him feel he's a top 10
off this week although I do like Michael
Gallup I like feeling a lot more should
I plague or Singletary is a flex from
jock and JC look I'm gonna leave towards
Gore to be safe just for now they just
haven't flipped that switch yet to
Singletary who is going to be active
today which defense will a dream the
Titans or the Saints I like a bolt I
kind of like the Titans against that
banged up Chargers olan member Russell
Poole not back just yet so I trust Josh
Allen verse Miami or go with Natron
against the Rams there's a dirty little
secret about the ribs
their defense really isn't that good it
hasn't been that good I know they just
chatted for Jalen Ramsey who's back
injury went away he'll go with Matt Ryan
so a patch of the homes for other
upgrades and roll with three
I would say you can think about that but
you got to know what breeze is coming
back and we don't know just yeah so you
need to have a back-up plan if freezes a
back yet do I start carry out or
singletary the TV only leak you got to
go carry on Johnson there
simple as that we go to the video board
for one of the questions from the people
hey Matt it's McKenzie I have to ask you
about the Ravens what are your thoughts
on Mark Ingram he's still a top back for
the Ravens but we've also seen at Gus
Edwards and just as he'll get some
touches this season do you think either
of these two men could become a bigger
threat for Mark Ingram for the second
half the Ravens season I know her from
somewhere I just can't place it
good question though talking about Mark
Ingram a very solid fantasy running back
to and we just talked about the
volatility of the position so far make
marking her mistake healthy he's on one
of the busiest rushing teams in football
we've seen a little of Gus Edwards here
a little justice Hill there but not
enough to really take away from Ingram
it also at the same time probably limits
him from being an rb1 I think you're
aware of this I think if you're in a
deeper league and you have Mark Ingram
if you pick up Edwards or justice Hill
just to have because if ingre were to go
down this team is still going to run the
football
it could be with both of those guys I
would guess Ingram gets or Edwards gets
a little bit of the lead but it's not a
bad idea investing in a rushing offense
is not bad however I'm sticking with
Mark Ingram because he has been pretty
solid alright
we're deal with by weeks and injuries so
you're gonna need some sleepers
[Music]
we keep you open-minded because of the
bye weeks and the injuries we did chase
Edmunds last week even with David
Johnson it worked out
quarterbacks where are the matchups how
do we follow those along let's follow
one here to get things going I know
Patrick Peterson is back for the
Cardinals well aware it's gonna be a
boost of their defense it's still not a
good defense and Daniel Jones has not
been good since he played the Buccaneers
in his first start there's no doubt
about that we get that but there's two
things first of all the Carnales defense
is still beatable and number two while
always favored the Giants passing game
there's volume there their defense is
terrible they have to throw the ball
more so maybe he throws a couple picks
but if he throws the ball 45 times
there's probably a 300 yard game in
there somewhere it doesn't have to be
pretty to get the job done I like Daniel
Jones with Ingram with a safe one
Barclay back and of course you still
have Golden Tate there as well alright
moving on from Daniel Jones by the way
Gardner Minshew still a sleeper for this
week goal Beasley Cole Beasley leads the
Buffalo Bills in targets just by one
over John Brown but it shows you for as
good as John Brown has been this season
this guy's been just as busy a very
solid player if you're in by week he'll
if you are dealing with injuries you
know we got Hollywood Brown up in the
air you're looking for a wide receiver
three you're looking for the last guy in
your lineup this guy's got a shot at 13
or 14 in the PPR this week he's done it
multiple times this year Josh Allen is
playing well the bills are playing well
he is somebody to think about a little
bit deeper at tight end he won't have a
graphic Dawson Knox
the tight end there for the Buffalo
Bills has been coming through I'll talk
about more on him later
now one more here I want to mention and
it's Darryl Henderson now you might say
well Todd Gurley is active and he is but
Todd Crowley's got a bad quad he's been
dealing with the knee issue dating back
to last season Malcolm Brown very likely
out today Darryl Henderson while he got
out snapped by Brown two-to-one last
week was a more efficient back and I
think the Rams need all hands on deck
plus they're playing the Falcons and
I'll give you a new narrative for us
we followed the Dolphins we also follow
the Falcons because they're not very
good either
not a bad flex option for Daryl
Henderson those are your sleepers there
for this week let's get to more of your
questions
right now what else do you guys have for
me because I know there's a lot of big
ones coming fells Darrin fells was in my
sleeper article or Darrin Waller we're
gonna play Waller especially with Tyrone
Williams out to speak congrats to him on
his new contract should I trade Melvin
Gordon and Amari Cooper for Alvin Kamara
I do not like trading into a high ankle
sprain so no you're not gonna make that
move Eric gee Phil Dede Westbrook or
Mike Williams we're gonna play Mike
Williams looks like Westbrook is going
to play today but I like Mike Williams
just a little bit more because I trust
this quarterback a little bit more so I
start Terry Maclaurin will fuller or
Ridley in a half point PPR I like fuller
should have had three touchdowns last
week dropped them all I think he makes
up for that this week a rare time I'll
tell you to sit Terry Maclaurin should I
start at Flex Golden Tate or latavius
Murray
I like Tate a little bit more for the
upside I think Murray's a safe play
depending on what you need now we answer
questions there we'll get to YouTube in
a bit I'll be in the app later on but
now I go out to the sports book because
people are watching and they're
traveling here and they need help as
well so I'm gonna bring it to them
alright hello sir what's your name hello
Marty uh your question for today yes my
question is what is the prospect of
quarterback position for the Kansas City
Chiefs you know we get these backups and
follow-up and you got Tannehill playing
for Tennessee and all that but nobody is
Patrick four homes and it's gonna
downgrade everybody across the board
it's not like I'm going to get Matt
Moore in my lineup a goal he's playing
for the Chiefs I do not feel that way at
all you still play entirely kill you're
still playing Travis Kelce outside of
that though it's gonna be tough to trust
the Chiefs and tough to trust Matt Moore
thanks man thank you all right there you
go we help out the people they're more
your questions coming up but now it's
time for a map moment I'm on the foot
too important call yeah
Lindsey a couple skate I think she's
down
no Monda Hoobastank level mom are you
serious I said in a minute
doing something sorry or you're welcome
that was teenage me and then adult me
grew up to wearing button-up flannel
that fits better I guess
teenage mean procrastinated that's we
were trying to get across their teenage
me was trying to put things off to the
end well guess what we're in week seven
week fourteen we'll bring you the
fantasy playoffs we're halfway there
if you're two and four right now you're
not feeling very good but you're not out
of it yet if you're sitting with the top
waiver wire priority spot number one you
got a bunch of fab money left in your
budget if there's a big name that pops
up let's just throw this out as a
hypothetical I hope it doesn't happen
let's say Dalvin cook goes down today
let's say Alexander Madison is out there
break the bank for him go get these guys
because we're running out of time you're
trying to make a playoff push you do it
right now if there's a big trade you
think you need to make go ahead and try
to make it injury optimism is out the
window we might not see AJ green until
after the trade deadline this might be
the time if you're two and four to trade
AJ Green to a team that's five and one
right now because you can't wait for him
to come back if you have Patrick mahomes
and you're three and three right now you
might want to trade patch balls cuz
we're not gonna see him for three to
five weeks and when you get them back
you could be completely out of it don't
be complacent and don't be contracted
for Aston ating anymore this is the time
to make the moves
that's your matte moment now back to
enact as we go oh hold on a second I
hear a knock at the door who's here
Maddi mellowness talk of procrastination
you break my heart once you help your
mother out okay okay mom why are the
bears procrastinating with David
Montgomery huh because you need to do
you want a snack all right I'll make you
something okay bye clean your room my
mom's 35 I swear I gave her all that
gray hair so David Montgomery why are
the Bears procrastinating I wonder the
same exact day and I warned you this
could happen he should be the man for
the Chicago Bears but they got to Rico
and they used all their receivers now
you got your Biscay coming back he's a
good player but is the opportunity gonna
be a clear path for the rest of the
season I don't see it being that way it
should be but that's just how Matt Negi
operates all right
that's where out with that now we go to
your questions we'll get to enact those
lifetime updates coming up in a little
bit but more your questions here and
these are from YouTube hello YouTube
let's take care of you Malcom Brown or
DK Metcalf Malcom Brown dry unlikely out
this week so you move on and play DKMS
calf instead
next one here George Kindle or hunter
Henry I'm gonna continue to play George
kettle as we saw debo Samuel is out
today next one up here
Josh Allen or Matt Ryan fair question
both in my top 10 but I like Matt Ryan
taking on at a beatable Rams defense
next one up here from toys and more
Amari Cooper DJ shark I'll tell you what
if you want to play it safe and play DJ
charts I got no problem doing so I
wonder about Cooper making it through
that entire game Cooper is the upside
play because of the matchup against the
Eagles Carlos Hyde or James White James
white wants to get a pretty safe play
against the job Jets on Monday night and
I would just go with that over Carlos
Hyde next one up here from Owen
Singletary or Robinson we're gonna go
with Singletary for that one those are
your YouTube questions speaking of a
Robinson Nate Robinson is here for you
right now
yo Matt listen I know you guys do the
whole fantasy thing I know
we'll went down and we got big guys
coming and stepping up yeah I got to
pick up mr. Wilson because guess what
Luke go and get the job done it's always
Russell Wilson one of the best
quarterbacks in football right now he's
hot so if you're doing fantasy I would
definitely pick up tight in for sure
because what's the Wilson that's
definitely gonna get it done just trust
me on this this is what I do all right
Nate this is what I do you did a PSA
there for the Seattle Seahawks you were
saying pick up Luke Wilson I'm not on
that train Darren fells tight end 13 for
the Houston Texans for the season not
for the Texas he's literally the number
13 sided for the season not a bad one to
look at this week and as I mentioned
earlier
Dawson knocks Buffalo Bills tight end
his snaps have risen each week for the
last month playing well bills are
playing well those are a couple tight
ends I would look at maybe even Dallas
Goddard today there's a bonus one I'm
throwing him in my lineup for this week
all right now we get back to inactives
who's in moves out we have some of these
we know already well update here Tyrell
Williams is out for the Raiders you'll
play in Darren Waller you're playing
Josh shakeups not a lot of confidence in
the other Oakland Raiders Davante Adams
is out not a surprise but Allison and
marques Valdes scantling you're both in
but their wide receiver three flexes to
me I can't get too excited about either
one I do bump up Jimmy Graham a little
bit because of Adams absence and
unfortunately Jamal Williams
is in the mix there for you Aaron Jones
owners Deebo Samuel is out there trying
to find this top Niners wide receiver I
don't think one exists maybe it gives
you a little bit more confidence to use
Pettis today but you're still rolling
with Kittel definitely Tevin Coleman and
Matt breed as the Flex Chris Thompson is
out makes it easier to ignore the
Redskins outside of scary Terry McLaury
David Johnson will play he's got the
ankle
he's got the back he's gonna play
through it he's a top 10 option I still
think chase Edmunds is a good flex play
Christian Kirk
being out is certainly part of that
Larry Fitzgerald should be very busy
today against the beatable Giants
secondary sterling Shepherd has the
concussion he's out but you'll notice we
do not see the names of say Quan
Berkeley or Evan Engram not on here
because why they're not even on the
injury report and Malcolm Brown doubtful
not expected to play today
you got Henderson as a flex as a sleeper
and
of course you're playing todd gurley as
a high-end RB - here's your late-game
inactives and what we know or at least
the injuries Walker up in the air later
on same thing with Marquis Brown throw
them in your Flex spots you have a
chance to use them Alvin Kamara and
Jarrod cook though I can tell you are
definitely out a lot of targets
available for Michael Thomas
feel free to spend on him a DFS and
latavius Murray is a solid flex option
with RB 2 up side Marty Cooper is
expected to play that somewhat of a
surprise I worry about him getting
through the entire game
I still like Michael gallop against the
poorest Eagle secondary Michener Biscay
is back today for the Bears
yeah I'm not excited about that either
Phillip Dorsett Julian Edelman listed as
questionable both expected to play
against the Jets on Monday night you
always play Edelman with confidence
Dorsett not a bad sleeper play against
the Jets because part of it is why Josh
Gordon is out this week so there you go
with all of your injuries now I got to
get moving it's time for the speed round
[Music]
seven weeks into the season am i moving
any faster coach you're getting there I
had a good talk with your mom earlier
she curses like a sailor I don't believe
it she said she's gonna make us both a
nicer calzone if you break the record
this week let's get it baby stay away
from my mother all right
speed round I got the headband on how
many questions can we get through to
help you out it's Preston Williams a
good flex option should I go after
Coomer off mvs doesn't play MBS is
playing I'll tell you to play a dolphin
for once in Preston Williams next one up
here from max walking Shepherd DeSean
and Hollywood are all hurt should I move
uh neon form any of it would be patient
look we know three to five weeks from
homes I can move on from Sammy Watkins
he was getting the job done anyway good
question there max
moving on to rude Stefon Diggs or
latavius Murray I don't love Diggs but
I'll play him over latavius Murray we
did see that he has some life in him and
he's got some really good leads to speak
Sonne Michele our Matt Frieda I'm gonna
lean towards Breda for the upside slowly
Michelle might be a tad bit safer
because he should get carries against
the Jets but bill bill come on give him
some carries at the goal line please
Shipley should I start Keenan over Soni
Michelle yes you should simple as that
I once again give him some carries at
the goal line that he's not getting Rock
Chalk is Jamal Williams worth the Flex
spot yes and I paint me to say that
because he shouldn't be but he has been
in the mix and the Packers can't quit
him he's a good pass blocker and Aaron
Jones owners I feel your pain I'm
wondering if I should flex Sanders over
maclaurin I guess it's mild Sanders
12-team redraft no I would play Terry
Maclaurin although I like what I'm
seeing four-mile Sanders playing Terry
you can't do it Allen Lazard our slate
not PPR flex you got both of those
Packers receivers in but you got Slayton
with Golden Tate and Ingram back I'll
play Allen Lazard off oh let's go to the
quarterback there Marlin mackerel avión
bells and flex I actually might play
Marlin Mac because I think Le'Veon Bell
will be the target for the Patriots to
shut down on Monday night Russell Wilson
at Homer Lamar Jackson on the road the
more Jackson's number one for me I have
Russell Wilson at like four you have a
trade to make oh my god you're killing
your Christians horn I don't
go get them stay away from it mom
gah freighter your Jones Brady's the
safe play if you want to go up side DAF
against the Falcons defense is a way to
go because the thousands defense thinks
try start mark Anders or Hunter Henry
I'm never gonna sit Mark Andrews has
been too solid this season Henry has
been - up and down next up here he's not
here I'm Tammy's murder deference
Singletary I'll go Murray because he
doesn't have the competition for carries
and touches like Singletary has with
Frank Gore traded Coleman Murray and
Williams tidal waves for gala day worth
it you might have given up a little too
much I'll say this be careful trading
away that much running back down
although if you're in a good spot son of
Baconator you're high up in the
standings you made a play to win
championship move Mike Williams and
laser Joe we're gonna go Mike Williams
there for you let's get another one in
I'm trying to go through Niners or Rams
Dee I'm not playing that Rams the
against the Falcons play the Niners
they're a good defense
- quarterback lead Dalton's my QB 1 oh
that's unfortunate
plates are Biscay or Jimmy J play Jimmy
G in Kyle Shanahan we trust there you go
I did it world record
there's a world record guinness come on
out to Vegas and you come on to Vegas or
join us here every single Sunday 11:30
Eastern 8:30 Pacific on all bleacher
report platforms I'll be jumping in the
app for the next 30 minutes to take your
week 7 questions I'm wearing flannel I
wore it before so I have to say have a
nice day i'm matt camp good luck in week
7 this has been your fantasy fire drill
thank you no I didn't hear it